ha sido médico investigador y director
de hospital pero a los 78 años se
encuentra su nueva carrera en un
supermercado de copenhague igual de
satisfactoria fleming simplemente no
está listo para renunciar al trabajo
conozco a cada uno de mis clientes
muchos por su nombre conozco a sus hijos
los he visto crecer y todos los días que
voy a trabajar Estoy feliz de quién
viene hoy
en este país que envejece donde el
número de trabajadores activos cae cada
año más y más personas mayores como
fleming Bruce leaf seguirán trabajando
porque en Dinamarca la edad de
jubilación está indexada en función de
la esperanza de vida ahora son 68 pero
para obtener una pensión pronto tendrás
que tener 72 o 74 para los daneses
nacidos después del año 2000 así en
copenhague como en una veintena de
municipios más las agencias de empleo
especializadas acompañan a las personas
mayores en su búsqueda de trabajo
la mayoría de las personas en nuestra
sociedad en Dinamarca son las personas
que son debido a sus trabajos eso es muy
importante a qué te dedicas Esa es la
primera pregunta que te hacen en
Dinamarca para ayudar a mantener
empleados a los adultos mayores es
ilegal que las empresas pregunten a los
solicitantes de empleo su edad y a
partir del próximo año el gobierno no
grabará los salarios de los jubilados
solo queremos incentivar incluso 5 horas
de trabajo 10 horas de trabajo 15 horas
de trabajo y también creemos que si
tiene la salud y la fuerza para hacerlo
también aumentará el valor ordinario de
la vida de las personas mayores así como
la producción en la sociedad
Así que es una vida hecha de más y más
trabajo en Dinamarca la tasa de empleo
de más de 55 años es mayor al 70%. en
Francia es del 56%